Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update we spoke to the developers of the
infamous series who said that the game
originally had a lot in common with
nintendo's animal crossing the
co-founder of Sucker Punch productions
chris zimmerman told GameSpot the
original idea for infamous believe it or
not was that it was a kind of animal
crossing but you were a superhero one of
the game's original pitches had players
fighting a gang of purple gorillas who
were stealing balloons zimmerman
explained we had all kinds of crazy
stuff like that we worked on that for
about a year it was much more stylized
much more cartoony than what you end up
seeing we worked hard to see if we could
make that work unfortunately we don't
have any images of this very early
version of infamous to share and
obviously the final game ended up going
in a very different direction the next
installment of the infamous series is
second son which launches on March 21st
exclusively for the PlayStation 4 for
more information on infamous second son
be sure to check out GameSpot's just
published coverage from our trip to
sucker punch productions